We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P, take a listen to
this voicemail asking a very incisive question
about the future of the David Pakman show.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David, this is Dave from California. After
the elections, it's rumored that you might
be an analyst on CNN or MSNBC. Well, that
mean you will still keep your show, the David
Pakman show or would you have to quit and
move to Washington DC or New York? Right.
Maybe you can clear up this rumor.
Yes, I am glad to
listen. Uh, I've been on CNN before and I've
even had meetings with talent, people at CNN
meetings that did not go particularly well
and it became clear they have no interest
in me doing anything on CNN. I've never even
been on MSNBC, which might surprise some of
you because it is the most editorial, the
left of the big three networks, uh, CNN, Fox
news and MSNBC. But actually MSNBC, it's sort
of a misnomer. MSNBC is so enshrined in centrist
leftism establishment leftism that they are
even less likely to have on someone like me
from the progressive independent left. So
no, there are no plans whatsoever along those
lines, quite frankly at this point, I don't
think it's really something I'm interested
in. My schedule is, is a pretty cushy and
uh, I don't know that I want to have bosses
and editors or any of that stuff, so I don't
see any scenario in which that is a what is
going to happen before, during or after the
election.
Rest assured, we've got a great bonus show
for you today. The women's March. Yes, there
was one if you didn't hear of it. That's part
of what we're going to talk about. The latest
women's March drew a much smaller crowd, but
still a very passionate crowd and I want to
talk about if and how that activism will translate
to November of 2020 and voting. We will also
talk about despite all of the claims from
Donald Trump about how great things are for
black voters and black Americans and how he
is more loved by black Americans. Then who
knows? He just says he's loved by them. Eight
out of 10 black voters say that Donald Trump
is a straight up racist in a new poll, so
we will talk about that. Additionally, we
knew that Trump's trade deal with China, the
phase one deal would be used to justify cutting
aid to farmers under the guise that they fixed
the problem, and indeed, the secretary of
the U S da is now saying the U S department
of agriculture says, we don't really need
the farm aid anymore because Donald Trump
made that great China trade deal. Of course,
that is not true. All of those stories and
more on today's [inaudible] bonus show, get
instant access by signing up@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].